James Corden is speaking out after he
was accused of being quote the most
abusive customer in 25 years by a New
York restaurant owner we're all going to
make mistakes everybody does courtin
tells the New York Times I haven't done
anything wrong on any level I feel so
Zen about the whole thing because I
think it's so silly I just think it's
beneath all of us it's beneath you it's
certainly beneath your publication
The Late Late Show was in repeats this
week and the times interviewer said
James was likely to address it in
Monday's broadcast but Gordon told us
before he's okay getting called out he
just touch up people around you who
challenge you and tell you that you're
being silly also moving on Real
Housewives of OC Stars Heather and Terry
Dubrow we do have life-changing things
happening this season you have purchased
a penthouse in La yep multiple sources
confirmed to E.T the couple is saying
goodbye to their massive Newport Beach
California mansion that we toured I tea
come on in for 22 000 square foot home
with 14 bathrooms a theater home gym and
an estimated 400 square foot closet with
a champagne doorbell sold for 55 million
dollars the larger sale this year in
Orange County and the area's third
highest ever so could the dubrows ditch
OC for another franchise cue the tease
garcelle and I have been friends for a
long time Ren and I have known it you
want to pick up a diamond
well I do enjoy diamonds let's let's be
clear as a New Yorker transplanted to La
dragged down to Orange County I'm
migrating home and from the OC to
Britain and the crown Netflix bows down
after Dame Judy Dench called it crude
sensationalism it cannot make it true
Dane Judy denge hasn't just launched a
scathing attack she has also said that
it should carry a disclaimer the house
of Windsor should be binding the nation
together Netflix is now describing the
show heading into season 5 as a quote
fictional dramatization she speaks for a
lot of people who feel that this series
really
really cool
too close to the bow
[Music]